a lot of people ask me you know what's  the best advice to someone who wants to  be a director and the answer I give is  very simple be a director pick up a  camera shoot something no matter how  small no matter how cheesy no matter  whether your friends and your sister  star in it put your name on it as  director now you're a director  everything after that you're just  negotiating your budget and your and  your fee so it's a state of mind is  really the point you never really get an  opportunity you take an opportunity in  the filmmaking business no one ever  gives you anything nobody ever Taps you  on the shoulder and say you know I've  really I've really admired the way you  uh the way you talk and the way you draw  it I think you'd make a good director it  doesn't happen that way you have to you  have to constantly be pulling on  somebody's sleeves saying Hey I want to  direct I want to direct I want to direct  and you have to be willing to make  sacrifices to to do that